so many people want this war to end
anti-war protesters across the globe
filled streets and squares over the
weekend you're looking at pictures now
police in russia arrested more than 4
300 people
some officers kicked and beat protesters
you can see the pictures again and in
toronto yesterday protesters carried the
ukrainian flag
and held signs showing support for
ukraine
people chanted no fly zone something
that is not materialized and in paris
people marched in republic square
shouting putin assassin
we're here on the ground in poland where
we are so close to the border in fact
that the time zone on our phone keeps
flipping back between ukrainian and
polish time
and you've heard about the humanitarian
crisis here well you're seeing it unfold
behind me the people in this picture are
taking their first steps into poland
their first step towards safety
and one of the things we've seen
are so many mothers carrying children in
their arms having had to leave strollers
and bassinets and cribs behind the
trains and buses are just so packed
and it made us wonder
what happens at that point when you
cross the border with nothing well it
turns out that at a release center not
far from here and in fact this morning
here as well there are some larger
donations the bigger stuff and that
includes strollers and baby clothes
something that calls to mind an image of
polish mothers the mothers of poland of
europe really mothers around the world
helping the mothers of ukraine
and that is an image i think that really
says it all
unfortunately there are other images
that tell a darker story one of extreme
need and that is the situation in the
white tent you see behind me
that is a warming tent it is the first
opportunity that people have here to get
out of the cold after long journeys i
took a look down there just a few
minutes ago and it was packed it was
packed yesterday it continues to be
packed
the spring really can't come here soon
enough guys along with what everybody is
hoping for those anti-war protesters we
began with
and the people here looking for good
news from their home country they want
an end to this war and they want it
yesterday
yeah yeah we do too it's so important
that you're telling the story tony so
people can see around the world what the
ukrainian people are dealing with
because they're not seeing any of these
images in the soviet in russia in the
soviet union they are not seeing it
no it's such a great point gail you know
it's become clear as the war has
unfolded that that putin is trying to
conquer not only cities in ukraine but
mines the minds of the people in russia
and it's it's a dark thought but a true
one that he's been in power for 22 years
there which means that many of the
soldiers fighting for russia have known
nothing else in their lives but putin in
power
all right tony decouple thank you so
much we'll be back with you a little bit
later on